[Music]
pretty little liars alum Shane Mitchell
and Gossip Girls Penn Badgley feeling
the love and the Philippines this week
while promoting their hit Netflix series
you now remember the thriller first
premiered on lifetime last fall but ever
since season one began streaming on
Netflix last month it is on track to be
watched by 40 million viewers here's why
it makes me tease binge worthy watch
list it's got romance sex and a sweet
guy with good hair saying swoon worthy
line ste was girl I'll be that guy the
one who sees you you deserved that only
slight problem is he's a stalker and a
murderer I was disturbed this guy I'm
really conflicted about him and bringing
him to life great writing and twisted
drama make you super binge worthy it's
also got fans thirsting over pens psycho
character Jo Milly Bobby Brown got heat
for this now deleted post he's no creepy
he's in love with her and it's okay so
I'm obsessed with that I've been
watching it and pence had to remind peep
hey creepy stalking and killing is not
okay one tweet said kidnap me please and
Penn replied no thanks another one
you're gorgeous I can see past that
crazy he said but you're supposed to see
past my face to the crazy it's the other
way wake up defined I have a million
followers I know what to say because all
it took was for me to start murdering
people y'all out of here he believes to
love exists hot doc therapists John
Stamos is another reason to binge he
shows up in episode seven and you could
also call you a lesson in what not to do
on social media you posted this hours
after I encounter the next thing our
little friend the internet gave me was
your address I'm very cautious about
what I put out there how much I put out
there and because of security and safety
reasons too you know I happen at a place
where I was like how did you know I was
here they're like oh we know the carpet
of the flooring of that hotel and I was
like okay note to self
that is some next-level super fandom by
the way there will be a season two of
you production is yet to begin but when
it does it will air exclusively on
Netflix
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]